The Ukrainian
capital of
Kiev is bracing
for more drone strikes tonight
after the Kremlin blamed Ukraine
for a drone attack on Moscow,
the first to hit civilian areas.
And the Russian capital.
Several residential buildings
were damaged and two people were injured.
Ukraine denies
any direct involvement in this attack,
but it's the latest sign
that the war could be entering
a new phase.
President Vladimir Zelensky
has even said
the timing of Ukraine's counteroffensive
has been set.
CNN's Jim Sciutto is here to break down
the very latest.
A lot has been going on
these last 24 hours.
You bring us up to speed.
So biggest thing is
that Ukraine is proving its ability
to strike in Russian
controlled territory.
Russian controlled territory inside
Ukraine taken over since the invasion,
but also
crucially inside Russia here, Kursk,
across the border in Belgorod,
Vantage.
But in Moscow
and on civilian targets there,
it seems with drones.
Now, Ukraine
has not claimed responsibility,
but they have not denied
direct responsibility for this.
But the key seems to be
showing it ability to attack
behind enemy lines,
even on the Russian homeland.
And the crucial timing here
is that
in advance of this highly anticipated
Ukrainian counteroffensive,
showing an ability to attack there,
but also keeping Russia on its toes,
so to speak.
You know,
they don't know
where they might strike next.
Yeah.
I mean, it seems as though it is.
I mean,
Vladimir Putin, for his part, has said
this is terrorist activity.
As you point out, though,
Ukrainians, top officials,
they are saying
we did not have direct
keyword involvement
in what happened in Moscow.
What more do we know
about how these drones were used
and who could be behind them?
So we don't know what specific
drones were used.
We do know that in the past,
Ukraine has
used old Soviet era drones.
Listen, this goes back to the seventies,
not as capable of drones as drones
as we know today.
But to your point,
they don't deny
directly
that were there
denying direct, direct responsibility.
They're not denying
any responsibility here.
And that's key because,
listen, we've talked a lot
about the Ukraine war.
Russia throughout
the war has attacked
Ukrainian civilian sites
in Kiev repeatedly,
including horribly in the last 24 hours
and going back
all across the country here.
So for Ukraine
to attack
a civilian target inside
Russia is a step and could create tension
between Ukraine and its NATO's backers
and the U.S.
for attacking civilian targets
because it has given them
the moral high ground
not to attack civilian targets.
To this point. Right.
And of course,
allies, including the US,
have given Ukraine tons of weapons.
But there's always been that concern
or that precondition
this should not be used.
That could be the red line here.
It's not clear that Ukraine has used
in fact,
there's no evidence that Ukraine
has used Western supplied weapons to
to strike Russian territory,
certainly civilian targets in Moscow,
and that could create divisions
between Ukraine
and its Western backers
if it were to use such weapons to do so.
Given
all the and purely understandable
and justifiable anger that the U.S.
and Western allies have have expressed
due to Russia's attack,
Russia's attacks
on civilian targets inside Ukraine.
Yeah, but it's interesting, too,
that the US supplied
Patriot missiles have really been helping
save lives there
in Ukraine in the wake of those attacks.
No question.
And they've been very successful.
And we should not
equate the two of these things
because Russia has been attacking,
first of all.
Russia attacked
Ukraine unprovoked
and it's been tried
in civilian targets for
for close to a year and a half
since since it invaded Ukraine
going back to February.
Can't lose sight of that for sure.
Jim Sciutto, thank you so much.
Well, let's get more perspective
now from former U.S.
ambassador to NATO, Kurt Volker.
He was also the US special envoy
to Ukraine.
Ambassador Volker,
thanks for coming on tonight
to this morning.
Russian President Putin
responded to the Moscow drone attacks.
Here's what he said.
He's here.
Do you know
Kiev chose the path of intimidation
of Russian citizens and attacks
on residential buildings.
It is a clear sign of terrorist activity.
So calling this terrorist
activity suggests
how seriously he takes this
and the kind of response he could take.
Do you think Putin might use
this moment as grounds
for even more severe tactics
Well, first off,
I think if Putin could use
more severe tactics,
he would already be doing it.
His forces are doing very badly
in Ukraine.
He's escalated the attacks
on Ukrainian cities already.
If he could do more, he would.
And I think his messaging here
is really about trying to reassure
the Russian public
who have got to be freaking out
that there are actually attacks
happening inside Russia now,
something that they had not seen before.
He's called this
a special military operation.
He has said that this is,
you know,
responding against
NATO's responding
against Nazis in Ukraine.
And now all of a sudden, there's
actually something
happening inside Russia.
This is putting pressure on him
and he's trying to control the narrative.
What does that do
in terms of public sentiment in Russia?
The fact that Russian civilians
are now feeling the effects
of this war on their own soil
Well, the first thing
is I think it's bringing home to them
the idea that this is actually a war.
Putin has tried to portray
this as a special military operation
far away,
dealing with something inside Ukraine
and fully justified.
And the fact that this is not
what's happening
is already evident to lots of people.
Russia's lost so many people,
so much equipment.
The war has gone on so long.
And now that they see
something inside Russia,
I think it adds to that confusion.
But one thing I want to come back to what
Jim Sciutto said,
which is making an assumption
that Ukraine was targeting
civilian targets.
We don't know that.
We don't know what the targets were
because
all of the drones that were fired
were shot down by Russia.
We don't know where they were going.
It could have been military targets.
We don't know.
We also don't know where they were fired
from. Or who did it.
And so I think we all have to assume
that Ukraine
would have facilitated this in some way.
But there's a lot we don't know.
So we shouldn't jump to assumptions.
Let's talk more about that.
And as Jim emphasized, you know,
Ukraine is
basically denying direct involvement.
But how critical credible is that?
I mean,
clearly, very careful words
selection there.
How credible is it,
especially given our previous
reporting that U.S.
intelligence picked up
chatter of Ukrainian officials blaming
each other for the Kremlin drone attack?
Yeah, well,
the first thing
is that remember last week
we saw these attacks
inside Russian territory in Belgorod
And these were all Russians
who are against Vladimir Putin
and who gathered some military equipment,
made an incursion
just to prove a point that they could do.
So they probably could not have done that
without some kind of tacit
Ukrainian support.
But at the same time,
it wasn't Ukrainians doing it
wasn't Ukraine conducting the attacks
as far as the drones go.
We don't know where they're fired from.
And I think that's significant
because it's a long way
from the Ukrainian border to Moscow
with a lot of air defenses along the way.
So for these drones
to get there, it indicates to me
they probably weren't fired from Ukraine.
But somewhere inside Russia,
even then, we don't know who did it.
It could be Ukrainian special forces.
It could be
these kind of Russian partizans,
and it could be facilitated by Ukraine
in some way.
There's just a lot
that is unclear about all of this.
All right, Kurt Volker,
thank you for offering your
perspective tonight.